le terrorisme on voit bien en france
prend ses racines dans une immigration
qui est une immigration non contrôlée et
de personnes qui se faufile dans
l'immigration aux classiques pour
rentrer sur notre territoire et faire et
faire ce type d'acte barbare
il ne faut pas avoir peur de faire un
d'avoir un débat sur ce sujet entre
immigration devant l'usma a laissé ce
débat au front national parce que moi je
vous promets dans les yvelines les
yvelinois quelle que soit leur
nationalité quelle que soit leur
confession ils sont dans une colère à
saisir de l'émotion qu'on ressent à
chaque fois sur le territoire
ça se transforme en colère et si la
colère n'est pas exprimé elle est sourde
et c'est encore pire saisir que les gens
sont prêt à éclater et ça peut se
traduire dans les urnes
et ça peut se traduire même de façon
plus plus plus physique
j'allais dire les gens sont exaspérés et
je pense qu'il faut mettre des mots il
faut agir voilà il faut le dire et ne
pas laisser ce sujet à marine le pen
voilà il ne faut pas laisser ce sujet au
front national est aujourd'hui beaucoup
d'argent de l'argent en france est de
l'argent bientôt européen en tout cas je
le souhaite et que notre déficit
français continue notre dette continue à
augmenter de façon très importante il
faut le faire c'est le moment pour le
faire il faut investir
mais à côté de ça il faut faire des
réformes qui sont des réformes
structurelles de notre appareil d'état
français ça passe par la réforme des
retraites mais ça passe aussi par une
réforme plus générale de l'état